i have to admit i am now turning from
bemusement to amusement as a
as an autonomous zone they are calling
it the capitol hill autonomous zone has
been set up in seattle protesters
have taken over apparently a six or
seven block radius in seattle and have
declared
their own state they've actually put up
a sign and says you are now leaving the
usa
not kidding the capitol hill free zone
they call it the autonomous zone is a
protester-occupied
zone okay it's sort of like the occupy
wall street routine that we saw a few
years back back in about 2010
and it is going to end up exactly the
same way it happened because the police
were told by mayor jenny durkin to
essentially withdraw from the area
and to cede the area to the cops and
it's turned into
a raucous comedy almost immediately now
i think that a lot of people across the
united states are feeling
that things have grown out of control
just a little bit
that no matter how much you believe that
police brutality is wrong and everyone
who is good believes this
and no matter how much you believe
racism is wrong and you don't have to
protest to believe that racism is wrong
it's kind of weird that we are now
talking openly about a complete takeover
of a major part of a major city
by protesters against the police where
apparently according to cops some
extortion is going on
the protesters have built walls they've
gone full trump guys they've gone full
authoritarian according to the left
right they've built walls not kidding
they actually built a wall to keep
people out they took over the east
precinct of the seattle police
department they called it the seattle
people's
department which is uh i'm really
enjoying this live showing on continuous
loop of the dark knight rises it's
really exciting stuff they set up
physical barriers
they apparently have armed people
patrolling the physical barriers
apparently they are stopping and
frisking people who are entering
i'm not kidding about this they're
stopping and frisking people who are
entering
and this was to get rid of the cops guys
this was to get rid of the evil horrible
seattle police department
and immediately upon that happening
people in there were like oh
you mean now there's power that's up for
grabs it turns out that anarchy
is usually a pretext for tyranny chaos
is usually a pretext for
terrible people taking over and so
according to
multiple reports essentially a warlord
is taken over
i mean we're looking at escape from new
york except it's escaped from seattle
we're going to send in
snake pliskin i mean all that has to
happen here is for
is for air force one to be downed inside
the seattle autonomous free zone
for things to get really wild so here is
exactly what went down
according to allah pundit over at hot
air
apparently seattle pd cracked down hard
on protesters on sunday night despite
the mayor having giving a speech earlier
that day calling for de-escalation in
order to lower the temperature the
week-long blockade by the police of
their east precinct was lifted
and demonstrators were allowed to march
past but that's not all apparently they
were afraid that the rioters were going
to burn down a police precinct so
instead the cops in the national guard
pulled out of the building entirely by
monday afternoon they removed all the
equipment in the files they boarded the
place up and they left
and thus was born a new nation the
capitol hill autonomous zone or
chaz for short which the country of chaz
a place where progressives can indulge
in some of the most humiliating
stereotype of left-wing protest
subculture according to reports
by early tuesday demonstrators had
established a perimeter with improvised
barriers and deputized scouts
in the afternoon the no cop co-op popped
up slinging kebabs snacks and free water
to passers-by
a teach-in square was established at the
intersection of 12th and pine bringing
it like a full maoist regime here
tents were pitched near the precinct
where people were encouraged to stay
throughout the night or even just for
two or three hours to hold the space
by nightfall they built their own
outdoor cinema the crowd was energized
to build connections people spoke about
investing in black owned banks divesting
from corporations and prison reform
one speaker issued a warning about the
american legislative exchange council
quote a group of usually white men
from major corporations who don't know
our issues and make laws
protesters hung a banner on the east
precinct that read property of the
people according to komo como which is
one of the local stations
and there are plenty of photos available
there's even a map replete with labels
like regime occupied safeway
regime occupied safeway solid stuff guys
really good stuff now people inside
come on this is this is beyond parody
it's like the right wing made this up
honestly it's it's as though it came
from the fever dream of like
of of thomas of tom wolf i mean that
that's what it feels like
activists who are claiming to have
helped create the police no-go zone
in seattle are now asking for food from
the outside
there's an activist who tweeted out the
homeless people we invited took away all
the food
at the capitol hill autonomous zone
you got rid of law and order and then
the homeless people came and took all
your food
because you're communist and this is
what happens you stupid communist
it's just it's delicious it's delicious
i like again my bemusement
so my my outrage at the destruction of
law and order turned to bemusement as i
watched the
mayor of seattle cave to all of this and
now it has turned to full-scale
amusement
as the thing turns into a predictable
debacle
according to one of the anarchists over
there
we need more food to keep the area
operational please if possible bring
you ready for this vegan meat
substitutes
fruits oats soy products etc anything to
help us eat
yes they're starving in there because
they don't have
the morningstar farms vegan breakfast
products we need those in there
right now this 18 year old activist
appears to be a transgender woman and
self-described lesbian anarchist
according to her now private
twitter account
well done everybody well i mean this is
and and so what are what are the
authorities doing about this no because
there are actual businesses and you know
people who are not crazy who live here
so what are they doing about this
nothing mayor jenny durkin who watched
her office is taken over the other day
by protesters at the behest of
councilwoman socialist councilwoman
shamosawant who's a full-scale idiot i
mean shamasawan is a person who occupied
boeing
and asked that boeing stopped making
military material so that they could
create buses for the homeless or
something like that
she's she's a crazy person shama sawant
so mayor jenny durkin
tweeted out in an effort this is june
8th right so three days ago
in an effort to proactively de-escalate
interactions between protesters and law
enforcement
outside the east precinct chief best and
seattle pd officers have removed
barricades surrounding these precincts
while safely securing the facility
in addition seattle fire has several
vehicles stationed near the precinct to
ensure emerging medical needs and fires
are addressed if necessary
keeping this area safe is critical there
are approximately 500 residential homes
in this block
as the chief takes this operational step
we'll continue to remain focused on what
we can and must do to address the
systemic inequities that continue to
disproportionately impact our black
resonance ah
so you're gonna just let people take
over a seven block radius in your city
in order to fight inequity
wow keeping demonstrations peaceful must
be a joint effort between our community
members
and law enforcement now it gets better
okay like the story gets better because
it is spectacular in every possible way
it is possible for this story to be
spectacular we will bring you
all of the details of the brand new
secessionist country that has been
established inside the united states
it's exciting exciting
stuff guys you're watching revolution in
real time
and it is it is comedy it is high comedy
guys this is high concept comedy right
here okay so fox news
had a reporter on the scene yesterday
explaining what was going on
inside this brand new country chaz the
country of chess
it's so good you see here's the reporter
from fox news on tucker's on tucker
carlson's show last night
a local station got video of several
guards armed with assault rifles
they are asking for identification
before letting people in
and police have received reports of the
armed guards demanding money from some
businesses
inside their area we also saw people
passing out food and what they call a
no cop co-op and they made a long list
of demands we have a full screen to show
you at least some of them
among them abolish the seattle police
department and the court system disarm
all cops until they are all fired
and abolish youth jails the mayor's
office did not respond to our requests
for a request for information about what
they plan to do next
so they're they're allowing these
crazies to take over like
this is a place where taxpayers live
this is a place where taxpayers live so
how's your whole abolish the police then
going if you're living in that area
is it going well for you by the way some
of the signs around the area are things
like
the cops will always be racist because
capitalism requires inequality
okay so you would imagine that there are
no cops now right i mean like this is
the whole point is to get rid of the
cops
wrong you are wrong you are the cops
are there they're just not called cops
so according to
reddit okay people have been posting on
reddit what exactly is going on there's
a person named raz
simone rasimone is a rapper apparently
he has been distributing
his rap mixtape to
to as many people as he can
i'm gonna read some of the comments okay
you ready this is so good
it's from a guy called wizard of the
future over at reddit
raz's crew is self-appointed heavily
armed has indicated their intention to
police the aryan has engaged in the use
of force
i am unaware of any rival street force
of their statue expressing the desire to
hold authority in the area
the power vacuum has apparently been
filled then
apparently one of the other comments i
only knew him from three years ago when
he gave my staff his mixtape when he
came into our work
and apparently people are tweeting out
things like raz is becoming the very
thing people didn't want to begin with
there's a video that is out of the
people working
with raz simone in in which
they are confronting people who are
graffitiing now apparently they only
want certain places graffiti because
they're certainly allies and they don't
want their businesses graffitied so
weird they want to protect the property
of people who they are allied with
but i thought that private property is
bad guys so they walk up to some people
who are graffitiing
these people who apparently work for
rasmon allegedly work for razimone
and the exchange is just glorious
because remember this whole thing
started about the evils of police
brutality
and authoritarianism and literally you
now have an armed force of people
in this seattle communist area
telling people we are the police now and
i will blow your brains out if you
resist
so police brutality went away for like
that long apparently and by the way
seattle cops aren't doing that seattle
cops are not doing that this is the
these are the woke the woke initiates
the woke army has arrived
i'm starting i want to start a gofundme
today any woke white liberals who are
working for mainstream media outlets if
you wish to relocate
to chaz to the capitol hill autonomous
zone
i will help pay your way if you pledge
that you will stay there if that you can
show
evidence that you are willing to stay
there for the entire duration of chas
is of of chaz's existence and you are
willing to
subject all of your bank accounts to the
tender mercies of jazz i am more than
willing to subsidize
your your immigration to this this area
outside the united states
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel so you don't miss out on
any of our content